THE FALCONS AND RAVENS AND A
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE NFL
PLAYERS ASSOCIATION.
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
NFL COMMISSIONER GOODELL, YOU
JUST HEARD HIM SAYING, THE
LEAGUE WON'T TOLERATE RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION AND THE NFL WILL
DEAL WITH IT IN A VERY SERIOUS
WAY IF THEY FIND IT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> I THINK ROGER, HIS HANDS ARE
TIED, HONESTLY, IN THE
SITUATION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LEAGUE
OFFICE, THE HIRES HE HAS CONTROL
OVER.
DIVERSITY IS PRETTY GOOD.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF WOMEN AND
BLACK MEN AND FORMER PLAYERS.
AND THE PROBLEM IS ONCE YOU GO
TO THE TEAMS, THE OWNERS HAVE
THE POWER.
OFTEN WE TALK ABOUT IT AS IF IT
IS AN INSTITUTIONAL OR SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM, WHICH WE'VE BEEN
CALLING IT THAT FOR A LONG TIME.
AND I THINK THAT GAVE THE OWNER
COVER, BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM LYING
IT IS SYSTEMIC OR INSTITUTIONAL.
IT FEELS INDIVIDUAL.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HIRE BLACK
COACHES HAS BEEN THERE.
IT IS THERE EVERY YEAR.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF BLACK
COACHES IN THE PIPELINE.
SOMEONE WHO HELD THE OFFENSIVE
COORDINATOR JOB AT KANSAS CITY,
A JOB THAT WAS HELD BY TWO MEN
PREVIOUS TO HIM, BOTH OF THOSE
GOT HEAD COACHING JOBS.
THE OWNERS ARE WILLING TO GO
OUTSIDE THE TRADITIONAL PIPELINE
TO HIRE WHITE COACHES.
JOE JUDGE, CLIFF KINGSBURY, JOSH
McCOWN HAS BEEN A FINALIST FOR
MANY OF THESE JOBS THAT HAD VERY
LITTLE COACHING EXPERIENCE.
SO I THINK WE HAVE TO BE HONEST
ABOUT WHAT THE PROBLEM IS.
THE PROBLEM ISN'T THE SYSTEM OR
THE INSTITUTION.
THE PROBLEM IS THE BIASES INSIDE
THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE
DECISIONS AND WHO HAVE THE
ULTIMATE POWER.
WE CAN'T BLAME ROGER FOR THIS.
HE IS DOING AS MUCH AS HE CAN.
THE PEOPLE ABOVE HIM, THE GUYS
WHO OWN THE TEAMS HAVE TO
CONFRONT THEMSELVES AND THE WAY
THEY VIEW THE CANDIDATES OUT
THERE AND MAKE HONEST CHOICES.
NOT THE CHOICES THAT ARE SKEWED
BY THEIR OWN BIASES.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
A GOOD POINT.
WE LIKE TO THINK OF ROGER
GOODELL BEING IN CHARGE BUT HE'S
NOT.
HE CAN'T MAKE ANYBODY WHO IS A
TEAM OWNER NOT BE RACIST.
RIGHT?
I MEAN, HE HAS NO POWER.
HE CAN'T SAY, HEY, BILLIONAIRE
NUMBER FIVE, STOP BEING A
RACIST.
>> YEAH.
THEY ELECTED HIM.
HE NEEDS TO KEEP THEM HAPPY.
IT'S NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER OVER
THEM.
THEY COME TO HIM TO DO THINGS
LIKE DID HE TODAY, WHICH IS ONE
OF MY POINTS, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS IS THAT WE TAKE
THE QUESTIONS TO THE OWNERSHIP.
ROGER'S JOB IS TO STANDUM AND US
TO RIDICULE HIM AND JUDGE HIM
FOR THE PROBLEMS IN THE NFL.
IN THIS CASE, THE ISSUES OF
RACIAL BIAS IN THE NFL.
HE TAKES THESE ARROWS WHILE THE
OWNERS CAN STAND IN THE
BACKGROUND AND CONTINUE TO KIND
OF MISTREAT THE CANDIDATES OUT
THERE AND BRING GUYS IN LIKE
DAVID, NOT GIVE HIM A FULL
CHANCE IN HOUSTON BEFORE YOU
FIRE HIM.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED IN
ARIZONA WITH STEVE WILKS.
OTHER BLACK COACHES GET THESE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT AREN'T TRUE
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO I THINK ROGERER IS DOING THE
BEST HE CAN.
ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE NFL.
ROGERER IS ONE OF THOSE WHO
WANTS THIS TO BE DIFFERENT.
YOU CAN'T GO INTO THE HEARTS AND
HEADS AND MINDS OF THE PEOPLE
MAKING DECISIONS AND MAKE THEM
FOR HIM.
SO I'M NOT SURE.
MAYBE IT IS SOMETHING, IT